willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung in der
wir uns mit fichtes system ja
sittenlehre befassen werden aber wir
wollen dieser sitzung noch eine art
hinführung unternehmen weil ficht das
philosophie nicht leicht verständlich
ist und wir wollen uns überlegen wie
sich das verhältnis zu kant genau zu
verstehen ist dazu wollen wir zunächst
ein brief lesen den fichte verfasst hat
in seiner zeit als hauslehrer oder
hofmeister
der davon handelt wie er kann zum ersten
mal begegnet ist nicht persönlich aber
in form seiner philosophie was ist bei
ihm ausgelöst hat dann wollen wir
fichtes begriff der wissenschafts lehrer
uns etwas genauer anschauen weil dieser
begriff für das verständnis des systems
der sittenlehre sehr zentrales weil das
ja wie es im untertitel heißt nach den
prinzipien der wissenschafts lehre
gebildet wurde und abschließend wollen
wir uns anschauen was kann über fichte
zu sagen hat ja jetzt kommen wir zum
ersten punkt den leitfragen was
faszinierte fichte so sehr und ganz
philosophie was versteht fichte unter
seiner unter einer wissenschafts lehre
und inwiefern ist für diese
begrifflichkeit von derjenigen ganz
verschieden da werde ich ein paar
methoden anwenden der die station
managers und eine begriffswolke
präsentieren wo man schon klar als sie
das hier verschiebungen gibt
was hielt kein verzicht des
wissenschafts länder das wollen wir uns
auch noch anschauen in einem brief an
seinen ehemaligen mitschüler in
schulzeiten friedrich august weiß kuhn
aus dem spätsommer sitze 90 schrieb
fichte folgendes ich lebe in einer neuen
welt seitdem ich die kritik der
praktischen vernunft gelesen habe setze
von denen ich glaubte sie seien
unumstößlich sind mir umgestoßen dinge
von denen ich glaubte sie könnten mir
nie bewiesen werden zum beispiel der
begriff in der absoluten freiheit der
pflicht und so weiter sind mir bewiesen
und ich fühle mich darüber nur um so vor
es ist unbegreiflich welche achtung die
menschheit welche kraft uns dieses
system gibt donnerstag in der sie es
längst werden empfunden haben wie ich
finde zentrale begriffe die sowohl die
philosophie kants als auch diejenige von
fichte betreffen
zum einen der begriff der absoluten
freiheit
der pflicht dass es ganz dick seien
pflicht ethik und die sind nicht nur
hingestellt und wir wissen deren
objektive realität ist bewiesen und dann
hier die achtung das ist auch ein
zentrales motiv bei kantig nach oben
rechts ein link zu einem anderen vortrag
über fichte theorie der achtung hinein
die achtung vor der menschheit menschen
hat jetzt auch ein wichtiger begriff von
kant und das werden wir uns jetzt
genauer anschauen weiter sagt fichte
welch ein segen für ein zeitalter in
welchem die moral von ihren grundfesten
aus zerstört und der begriff der pflicht
ich ein fördert durch und durch strichen
war denn verzeihen sie mir ich
überredete mich nicht dass vor der
kantischen kritik irgend jemand der
seinen verstand selbständig zu augen
musste anders gedacht hat als ich und
ich erinnere mich niemanden gefunden zu
haben die gegen ein system etwas
gründlichere angewendet hätte etliche
leute habe ich genug gefunden die anders
nicht dachten das konnten sie überhaupt
nicht sondern fühlten so täuschte es
mich durch die scheinbare konsequenz und
enttäuscht ist vielleicht noch 1000 was
ist das für ein system und die täuschung
die fichte hier anspricht ein
scheinbares system das ist das gefühl
hatte etwas anderes
als er in dem system gedacht hatte ja
dazu hilft ein blick entwicklers
bestimmung des menschen an ihre
popularität ist berg aus dem jahr 1800
da sagt fichte folgendes das system der
freiheit befriedigt sind gegen gesetzte
tötet und vernichtet mein herz kalt und
tod dastehen und den wechsel der
begebenheiten nur zusehen ein träger
spiegel der vorüber den gestalten dieses
dasein ist eine unerträglich ich
verstehe und verwünscht es also system
der freiheit was sie gibt es bei kant
glaubt gefunden zu haben das free dick
das entgegengesetzte das system ist
determinismus oder auch des zweifels des
freiheits skeptizismus könnte man sagen
das töten empfindet es ist kalt und tod
ich bin nicht und ich handle nicht sagt
fichte wenn ich das gehöre der
gegenstand meiner innigsten zuneigung
ist ein hirngespinst eine gräfliche
nachzuweisende grobe täuschung stadt
meiner ist und handelt eine fremde ganz
unbekannte kraft und es wird mir völlig
gleichgültig wie die sich entwickler
geschehen stehe ich da meine herzliche
neigen und mit meinem guten willen und
erhöhte vor dem was ich für das beste an
mir erkennen und umsetzen will mich
allein sein mag als vor einer
lächerlichen tragt main hall existence
dem sport preisgegeben was ist jetzt das
heiligste
vielleicht ja das herz ja das herz das
herz ist die freiheit die individuelle
freiheit sich nach den individuellen
prinzipien entscheiden zu können nicht
determiniert zu sein
weiter geht es in diesem brief an seinen
schulkollegen weiß wo ich habe mich
jetzt in die kantige philosophie ganz
geworfen anfangs außen rot ich glaube
eine stunde über die kritik der reinen
vernunft nachher seiten einer
bekanntschaften der kritik gestoßen es
war am geschmack ein gewisser polka in
schlesien hat eine darstellung der
kritik der reinen vernunft selbst kurzer
widerlegung der dagegen gemacht und
einen für geschrieben ist ein
größtenteils ein auszug der mir indes
trefflich erscheint der nicht arbeiten
konnte nicht freut weil ich halb und
halb wien zwar etwas ähnliches zu tun
also dieser zeit gab es ganz viele
versuche kann es für die damaligen
generation unbegreifliche philosophie
die auch sehr umfangreich war
verständlicher darzustellen das hat auch
richtig versucht hat es in
religionsphilosoph geschrieben sich
genau mit seinem versuch einer kritik
alle offenbarung diese schrift erschien
anonym und alle hielten sie vor allem
wieder gekannt und dadurch würde fichte
schlagartig berühmt jetzt wollen wir uns
mit fichtes begriff ist schaffts leser
auseinandersetzen über den begriff der
wissenschafts jährige sogenannten
philosophie also die wissenschaft lehre
ist die sogenannte philosophie von 17 94
hier schreibt er dass die philosophie
eine wissenschaft ist
das ist die einzige objektive einigkeit
sagt er die über die philosophie besteht
dass sie eine wissenschaft ist da möchte
ich ein bisschen zweifel anwenden wenn
sie heute mal fragen auch unter
philosophen oder philosophen das opfer
so viel wissenschaft ist dann werden
dass sehr viele bestreiten auch zwei aus
guten gründen warum meine philosophie
keine empirischen ergebnisse erlangen
kann und auch nicht falsifiziert bar ist
und häufig sagt man wissenschaftlicher
fortschritt kommt dadurch zustande dass
eine theorie prognosen macht und diese
prognosen dann falsifiziert werden durch
andere tierische
begegnungen und dadurch muss die theorie
revidiert werden und wieder besser
angepasst werden und zu nähern wir uns
vielleicht schritt für schritt der
wahrheit wenn es die wahl gebaut gibt
aber es gibt keine wissenschaft die ohne
empirische experimente wissen erlangen
kann fichte behauptet dass aber gerade
eine wissenschaft sagte weiter hat eine
systematische form und die sind in einem
einzigen konzert vereinigt in einem
konsens hängen die zusammen
und das ist jetzt der punkt es gibt zb
eine theorie eine wissenschaft die
glaubt wissenschaft zu sein wenn sie ein
luftschlösser baut luft drin gespinste
wie hier daß es in der luft geschöpfe
mitmenschliche neigungen leidenschaften
gibt
luftgeist position system auch wenn es
noch so konsequent ist es ist keine
wissenschaft warum
weil es einfach nicht fundiert ist es
hat keine evidenz
anders hingegen die geometrische setzte
die haben evidenz wegen der aktion auf
dem sie passieren ja ohne zweifel darum
weil das erstere also dieses
hirngespinst enthält nichts was man
wissen kann dass letztere die schul
gerichte form fehlt hier sagt die
geometrischen sätze sagen das wissen
vorhanden ist und können das wissen auch
wirklich bekannten ja
also das ist hier der punkt dass es eben
ein system habe immer eine systematische
form in dem gesetz zusammenhängen des
systems und mit einem grundsatz von dir
sind
ja das ist also die
fundamentale anforderungen eines systems
das es einen grundsatz hat
jetzt sagt er hier dieser schlechthin
gewisses satz der grundsatz der kann
nicht aus der vereinigung mit an
grundsätzen seiner gewissheit erhalten
sondern muss sie selbst besitzen um die
anderen setzen müssen jetzt jährige
weshalb durch diesen satz erhalten
ja da sagte nochmal unten einer solchen
vor ein solcher vor der verbindung
vorher und unabhängig von ihr gewisser
satz heißt ein grundsatz das ist die
absolute grenze hat uns fragen uns
natürlich was uns der grundsatz des
wissenschafts wäre darauf kommen wir
gleich noch zu sprechen jede
wissenschaft muss ein grundsatz haben
sonst wäre sie gar nicht wissen schafft
und wenn der sagt dass meine grundsatz
gewiss sein müsse auf usb wenn diese
gewisser müsse arbeitet so weiter
gewissheit und durch diese verbindung
entsteht dann das ganze system das
könnte man jetzt die systematische
positivität der gewissheit nehmen der
grundsatz der leitet seine gewissheit
über
bbc weiter das ist in der lage die
transit ivi tätigte möchte ich aber
keine logische theorien wie könnte
aufgehen auch gleich noch näher ein es
sagt die wissenschaftlerin sowohl sie
eine logische form hat von der logik
streng verschieben wir müssen sie
nämlich fragen ist wirklich absolut
gewiss was begründet haben wir dieses
diesen grundsatz wirklich zu behaupten
oder zu setzen wie fichte aus
entscheidend ist ja auch noch das die
systematische form befürchtet sagt nicht
der zweck der wissenschaft ist so nur
etwas zufälliges nur deswegen nötig ist
weil dadurch die ganze einheit
gewissheit bekommt das ist das
organisationsprinzip was aus der
gewissheit anforderungen folgt sie ist
nicht das wesen dieses thema der
wissenschafts und eine zufällige
eigenschaft dass das alte system ist nur
eine form der gewissheit die ihr diese
gewissheit nachgeordnet ist die
eigentliche form die eine gewissheit
annehmen kann oder muss ist das system
aber das system hängt immer von der
gewissheit ab es ist dem zweck die
gewissheit erweiterung nachgeordneten
deswegen treffen auch viele vorwürfe
nicht so dass es nicht nur man ab sagte
system ging wie zum beispiel
schopenhauer an andere vorgeworfen haben
sondern es geht richte und die
gewissheit die eben notwendigerweise
nach seiner theorie systematische form
annehmen was ja da sagt bring dir eine
schöne allegorie die wissenschaft zahlen
gebäude der hauptzweck dieses gebäudes
sei festigkeit der grund ist fest so wie
dieser gelegt ist wäre der zweck
erreicht also man kann aber den bloßen
krone nicht ohne denken sie sich so ein
fundament das ausgegossen wird daran
kann man nicht wohnen und auch noch ein
dach im topf dass uns auch schützt gegen
die witterung zum beispiel was ist die
gitarre diese allegorie das ist der
skeptizismus also wir müssen ohne
systemen deswegen aufbau um uns vor
skeptizismus zu schützen damit unsere
gebäude nicht zusammenfällt dh sie
müssen alle in diesem grund setzen und
dadurch erhalten sie ihre festigkeit
gegen die anfeindungen lief ich das sagt
des skeptizismus des skeptizismus gehen
theoretischer hinsicht dass wir nichts
wissen können dass kapitalismus in
moralischer hinsicht dass es moral nicht
gibt das alles muss subjektives oder
auch das feiern skeptizismus dass wir
nicht reisen determiniert sender er hat
das ist also dieser kommt von dem fichte
spricht
aus diesem grundsatz folgend
verschiedene sätze und sind nur durch
diesen gewiss
ja das ist der punkt das ist die form
der wissenschaft jetzt fragt er wie ist
der gehalt und form einer wissenschaft
überhaupt wie ist die wissenschaft
selbst nicht jetzt fragt er nicht nach
besonderen bisschen wie die geometrie
sind nach der wissenschaft als solcher
man könnte jetzt sagen dass das sie eine
wissenschafts theoretischen frage ist
die fichte aufwirft doch muss man
zugestehen dass heute und der
wissenschaftstheorie das ganz anders
verstanden bestanden dass ich dir hier
hat eine realistische theorie die mit
absoluten gewissheiten operiert die die
heutige wissenschaft gar nicht kennen
auch die heutige wissenschaftstheorie
als disziplin der philosophie nicht mehr
auf diese weise vertritt etwas sagt
wichtel worin diese frage beantwortet
würde wäre selbst eine wissenschaft die
die frage wie eine wissenschaft selbst
möglich ist und zwar die wissenschaft
von der wissenschaft überhaupt einen mit
wissenschaft und das ist die philosophie
darum geht s sicht also die begründung
von wissenschaft überhaupt spricht von
gewissheit und der frage wie gewissheit
systematisch entwickelt und ausgedehnt
werden kann die stellt sich hier
ja ganz unten könnte man noch sagen oder
etwas weiter oben
das eben die philosophie so etwas sein
könnte
ganz unten sagte die bisher so genannte
philosophie wäre demnach die
wissenschaft von einer wissenschaft
überhaupt überhaupt ist auch noch
richtig das ist die prinzipien
wissenschafter schlechthin ja jetzt mir
wollen wir uns noch die frage stellen
wie sich die allgemeine wissenschafts
lehre zu logisch wir hatten ja gesehen
wissenschafts während sind transit eve
fungiert durch den grundsatz aber das
ist doch eine ideologische relation er
sagt die wissenschaft lehre soll für
alle möglichen wissenschaften die form
aufstellen nach der gewöhnlichen meinung
an der wohl auch etwas wahres sein markt
die logik das gleiche könnte auch sagen
ein system muss nur nach logischen
prinzipien fungiert sein oder
konstruiert sein es braucht nicht noch
mehr dazu wie verhalten sich diese
beiden wissenschaften die wissenschaft
lehre und die logik und wie verhalten
sie sich insbesondere in der absicht
jenes geschäfts der sich beide anmaßen
das ist jetzt die spannende frage in der
wissenschafts lehrer nämlich sagt fichte
sind gehalten vom notwendig vereinigt
die logik soll die bloße form vom
gehalte abgesondert darstellen diese ab
sondern kann da sie keine ursprünglich
ist nur durch freiheit geschehen die
frei absonderung der bloßen form von
gehalten wäre es so nach wodurch eine
logik zustande käme man nimmt eine
solche absonderung abstraktion und die
nach besteht das wesentliche in der
abstraktion allem gehalt dieser
wissenschafts und logik ist nur formal
sie ist etwas abstraktes vom gehalt und
deswegen lassen nach glauben dass die
logik ist nicht primär hieraus ergibt
sich dass bestimmte verhältnisse logik
zur wissenschafts lehre die erstere
nämlich die logik gegründet nicht die
letzte sein die letzte begründet die
erste die wissenschaftsjahre kann
schlechterdings nicht aus der logik
bewiesen werden und man kann man darf er
keinen einzigen logischen satz auch den
des widerspruchs also war es nicht
gleich nun nicht als gültig
vorausschicken hingegen muss jeder
logisches satz die ganze logik aus der
wissenschaft lehre bewiesen werden also
die wissenschaftstheorie philosophie ist
nach der logik voran
das ist natürlich ein hoher anspruch den
fichte hier stellten jetzt bringt ein
beispiel glas eine tautologie
dialogische ist ohne zweifel ein logisch
richtigen satz in analytischer satz und
insofern oder eine tautologie insofern
er das ist ist seine bedeutung die wm
gesetzt ist so ist park es entstehen
hierbei die zwei fragen die szene
gesetzt und in niefern und warum ist
gesetzt wenn es gesetzt ist oder wie
hängt jenes wenn und diese so
zusammen setzte tal obigen satz bedeute
ich und ich und habe also sein
bestimmten gehalt zu hieße der satz
zuvörderst ich bin ich oder wenn ich
gesetzt bin so ging nicht gesetzt aber
weil das objekt ersatz des apsolute
subjekt das subjekt schlechthin ist so
wird in diesem einzigen fall mit der
form des satzes zugleich seien in hall
gehalt gesetzt ich bin gesetzt weil ich
mich gesetzt habe ich bin weil ich bin
die logik sagt also wenn da ist ist a
die wissenschaftspolitische weil diese
stimmte gleich ist ist
und hierdurch würde die frage ist denn
dieses stimmte a gesetzt sobald es ist
gesetzt wenn es ist gesetzt es ist
unbedingt schlecht dahin ersetzt also
hier geht es pflicht jetzt nicht um ein
individuelles selbstbewusstsein sondern
wie er sagt um das absolute subjekt das
subjekt schlechthin das trifft uns alle
individuen wir haben immer das
selbstbewusstsein was er hier sagt ist
dass unser selbstbewusstsein
material der bloßen logischen identität
vorangeht das ist dieser grundsatz
dieses ich bin ich
setze da in obigem satz bedeutet mich
dass ich sei irgend etwas andere so
lässt sich aus dem obigen die bedingung
einsehen unter welcher man sagen könne
als gesetzt und wie man berechtigt zeit
zu schließen will angesetzt ist so ist
das gesetz nämlich der science park
gleich ergeht ursprünglich er ist von
dem satz der wissenschaft lehre ich bin
ich abgezogen alle gehalt also rauf
anwendbar sein soll muss ich liegen und
ihm enthalten sein keiner kann etwas
anderes sein als ein im gesetz dass und
nun hier der satz so was im ich gesetzes
ist gesetzt ist im ich gesetzt so ist es
gesetzt insofern es nämlich gesetz ist
alles möglich möglich und notwendig und
so ist er und widersprüchlich war wenn
dass ich sein soll ist für das nicht
gesetzt weil es gesetzt ist so ist alles
was ich gesetzt dass bis jetzt weil es
gesetzt ist wenn nur etwas mit gesetzes
ist so ist es gesetzt wenn es gesetzt
ist schon die zweite fahrgast auch
beantwortet es gibt also damit dass
dieses selbstbewusstsein nicht so rein
formal ist wie dieses paar gleich aus da
ist mehr dahinter das ich setzt sich ja
das heißt da ist eine tätigkeit
sieht man dass cs muss dann halt immer
etwas praktisches und haus folgt dann
auch das ist etwas aperiodische
synthetisches ist nicht nur wie die lok
gegners akribisches analytisches und
jetzt können wir uns fragen liefern ist
wichtig philosophische begrifflichkeit
von derjenigen kann's verstehen ich habe
sie nur ein paar auswertung um genommen
anhand von digital humanities methoden
von bauland tool das findet sich im
internet kann ich sehr empfehlen einmal
das erste bild ist verpflichtet begriff
der wissenschafts lehre hier sehen wir
satz form grundsatz wissenschaft begriff
wissen das system gewiss das sind diese
bedingungen die es ihm geht und dann
haben wir hier noch die einleitung von
fichte system der sich mehr und mehr
bewusst sein bewusstsein tätigkeit
wirksamkeit gesehen es ist nicht nur
abstrakt so es ist immer in ihrer
tätigkeit gesetzt bestimmt begriffe
objektiv schlecht ziel gesetzt hier
sehen wir zusammen begriffe und wenn wir
das jetzt mal vergleich mit einem auszug
aus kants kritik der praktisch hier
unten dann sehen wir hier spielt das
gesetz eine große rolle die maxime die
vernunft kommt häufig die gar nicht vor
diesen texten die jetzt hier analysiert
habe maxime gesetz also was hier bei
fichte die wissenschaft lehre ist oder
die vernunft bekannt ist bei fichte das
bewusstsein und der grundsatz ist
vielleicht das gesetz so könnte man das
vielleicht zahlen also hier verschieben
sich einige begrifflichkeiten sehr
entscheidend und jetzt hat kann
interessanterweise noch eine reaktion
veröffentlicht auf wie ich das
wissenschafts länger er versagt nämlich
erklärt das nicht des wissenschafts
mehrere für ein gänzlich unhaltbare
system halt denn reine wissenschaft
lehre das ist das was wichtig sich
vorgenommen hat ist nichts mehr oder
weniger als klose logik welche mit ihren
prinzipien sich nicht zum materialen des
ergebnisses für steigt sonst inhalte
derselben als reine logik abstrahiert
also genau andersrum als richter betont
hatte aus welcher ein reales objekt
heraus zu glauben vergeblich und bei ok
versuchte arbeit ist sondern wo wenn es
die trends and a philosophie gilt alle
erst zur metaphysik über geschritten
werden muss also kann sagt fichte wenn
du beansprucht durch eine wissenschaft
lehre
gehalte also material erkenntnissen
synthetische erkenntnisse zu erlangen
und das auch noch apriori glaubt tun zu
können dann bist du eigentlich ein
metaphysischer und hast die kritischen
grenzen überschritt weil die immanuel
kant gezeigt hatte erkenntnis nur durch
anschauen und begriff möglich ist
wichtig philosophie hat keine anschauung
empirischen sinne wie es verkannt
wichtig ist es gibt noch die mathematik
und geometrie die auf der reinen
anstands form basieren aber das sagt ja
fichte auch nicht wichtig versucht das
alles aus dem objekt heraus zu glauben
aus dem subjekt genau genommen und hier
sagt kampf macht eigentlich nichts
anders als eine bloße logik die nicht zu
materialien gehalten kommt wie er als 7
grad was aber metaphysik nachricht des
prinzipien betrifft so bin ich so wenig
gestimmt an derselben teilzunehmen da
sicher im antwortschreiben ihm statt der
fruchtlosen spitzig spitzfindigkeiten
seine gute darstellung gabe zu
kultivieren rät wie sie sich in der
kritik bereits mit nutzen anwenden lässt
aber von ihm mit der erklärung er werde
doch das klassische nicht aus dem augen
sitzen höflich abgewiesen wurde also ist
die frage ob ich den geist der
wichtigsten philosophie für echten
krediten seite durch ihn selbst
beantworten ohne dass es nötig haben
über ihren wert oder unwert abzusprechen
da hier nicht von einem brot halten wird
sondern den beurteilen subjekt die rede
ist wo es genug ist nicht von einem
anteil angela philipps loszusagen
also kann sagt dass richter in seiner
wissenschaft lehre
fruchtlose spitzfindigkeiten unternimmt
also feste reihen nämlich der versucht
aus dem ich alles abzuleiten
hierbei ist erkannt musik noch bemerken
dass die anmaßung die mir die absicht
und wird verschieben ich habe bloß eine
bedeutung zu 315 nhl philosophie nicht
das system dieser philosophie selbst
liefern wollen mir unbegreiflich ist das
hat mir eine solche absicht den gedanken
kommen können da ich selbst das von ende
die ganze der reinen philosophie der
kritik der einen und für das beste
merkmal der wahrheit dass sie gelesen
habe das heißt wichtig scheint versucht
zu haben kannst ein zitat würde so viele
nur als eine gruppe tätig also eine
vorläufer theorie aufgefasst haben auf
der dann seine wissenschaft lehre noch
wie eine wirkliche trans endlose
auftreten kann das hat natürlich kann so
nicht gesehen so dass ihm hier sehr
heftig widersprochen ja
gibt es noch ein letztes zitat also hier
sagte
dass eben man sich in acht nehmen muss
zu einer unkritischen philosophie
verpflichtet philosophie so kann
lässt die kritischen grenzen hinter sich
weil sie eben nicht mehr wie es kannst
philosophie betonte auf anschauung
angewiesen ist philipp viele möchten
eben das nicht tun
möchten aus der reinen begrifflichkeit
gehalte entwickeln und das stellt kann
in frage ja vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit